hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 24th 2017 what's going on
how I yeah I got to keep my voice down I
got my little little one here is
sleeping in the next room I am in New
York City I got a little acting gig here
on a little movie in a little city
called New York City for the next week
I'll be doing that [ __ ] so I'm acting
during the day and night whenever the
hell they have me doing it and then I'm
looking I come home and I look at the
scripts that were working on Epis for
family and I don't know that's become my
life here I actually did one spot this
weekend though I went over to the Gotham
comedy club had been there in [ __ ]
years went over there had a great time
and try to maybe pop in and do another
spot maybe next weekend or something
just you know so I don't forget all my
[ __ ] jokes but Jesus Christ his New
York changed I can't believe it like
everybody lives in Brooklyn now I don't
know I mean there's a bunch of people
still living in Manhattan but like I
don't know Manhattan's weird now like
they they took it too far
I guy remember when I first lived here
like Manhattan was it was scary like you
were always kind of you know being aware
of people around you I remember buying
like a jacket a hat trying to look
tougher than I really was just trying
anything you could do to you know keep
that [ __ ] thing off you and and even
then I guess it was way but obviously
going to was in the 70s and the crack
80s and everything in Giuliani had just
taken over but somewhere along the line
man they they they just took it too far
I felt it wasn't like Sacramento or
something
you know not saying there aren't
dangerous parts of Sacramento those
dangerous parts of it it just felt like
it didn't feel like New York like there
was just no there was no vibe I guess it
was kind of cool you know like families
and [ __ ] it kind of just it's starting
to feel like a theme park I know it's a
weird thing to complain about that it's
it's like too safe but it's just I don't
know I'm probably just a grumpy old man
it's definitely not the city idol number
so I was out in Brooklyn you know
rehearsing some of the [ __ ] that I got
to do for next week and just going
through day oh my god all the [ __ ]
high-rises oh my god all the [ __ ]
high-rises and [ __ ] that they're
building over there and it's it's just
not I'm advised to date this woman that
[ __ ] lived off the G train like
[ __ ] 15 years ago it was like it was
like going to another [ __ ] world and
now you go I don't want the [ __ ] going
I don't know I'm just an old man going
this is nowhere I used to be you know I
went over there that's like we're all
like the hipsters but even everybody's
so anti hipster that even hipsters don't
dress like hipsters anymore but you can
still see him you know now the new vibe
is you sort of like you have like the
Conor McGregor haircut with the Good
Charlotte tattoos and clothes you know
so you kind of look like does this guy
build custom motorcycles or does he ride
a tricycle with the giant front wheel
you know is he making his own brew is
the you know is he working on those
[ __ ] breweries you know it's none of
that
you know the Michael Jackson pants that
don't quite make it down to your [ __ ]
sneakers or shoes or whatever the [ __ ]
they are so I don't know like Brooklyn's
like it's like nice now I don't know
[ __ ]
it was yeah Jesus Christ what I want to
know is where did all those people go
when they write it all up like where do
all the rest of the people go where all
those restaurants go where does that
vibe go all that culture where the [ __ ]
does it go everything just looks like a
[ __ ] forever 21 now and everything is
just a giant glass luxury [ __ ]
apartment building whoo [ __ ] has all
this money
I thought these [ __ ] Millennials were
broke they were coming out of college
with all this college debt and there
were no [ __ ] jobs and all I do you
know I know what's going on you trying
to buy a house right now it's like if
you don't like you try to buy a house
into some Chinese guy or guy from the
Middle East or a Russian guy that just
comes in and just [ __ ] digs all cash
I think this is my [ __ ] conspiracy
theory that Russia China in the Middle
East are in cahoots with each other
they're like look well we can't like
just go over and start bombing those
guys you know the United States have
nuclear weapons and as we saw in world
war ii they will use them not once but
twice right so they know they can't do
that so I think what they're doing now
is they're just going to [ __ ] just
slowly buy as much as they can and put a
Chinese guy a Russian or an Arab in all
of those and then they'll be they'll
have infiltrated our country then
they'll run for office and then they'll
just switch the whole [ __ ] thing do I
sound like that guy talking about bottle
our precious bodily liquids or fluids in
dr. Strangelove
I don't [ __ ] know I think this is a
part of being my age where like you live
long enough that you remember how it
used to be and now you're seeing it
changing it's kind of freaking you out
maybe that's what it is maybe I'm just
one of those guys being like wow you
know when I die someday like no one's
going to give a [ __ ] and this is just
going to keep going isn't it I guess I'm
not that important
anyways I'm [ __ ] got my handheld
goddamn recorder here because yeah cuz
I'm on the road and I didn't have any
room to bring all my podcast [ __ ] cuz I
got the kid now and that's a [ __ ] trip
huh packing up all your stuff all the
stuff you need for the kid and it's not
that bad you just pack it all up and
then you just go to curbside [ __ ]
hand somebody at 20 and just be like
yeah just shovel this [ __ ] out of the
plane and that's it then you get one of
those giant wheelie things when you land
you just wheel it out you throw it all
in a cab alright then you yank it out
and then you got the guy at the hotel
you [ __ ] people sit on a wheel II
think it's really not that bad everybody
acts like they have to carry it and
[ __ ] hold it in their lap on the
plane ride you don't just pay the extra
money shove it under the [ __ ] plate
and be done with it but my daughter did
great on the plane you know I guess kids
before they're like 1 years old like the
the air pressure stuff doesn't quite bug
them as much I don't know why maybe
they're eustachian tubes they're so
small they don't understand why it
wouldn't but people claim that it
doesn't you know and for those of you
who don't understand that you're popping
thing which I didn't it's just you know
when you take off the air inside your
ear on the other side of your eardrum is
that pressure as you ascend becomes
higher than the pressure on the other
side of your eardrum the outside product
right that leads to the the little
[ __ ] escape hatch on the side of your
head right so there's that difference in
air pressure we all know high pressure
always goes to low pressure and it takes
the most direct route which is you know
pushing against your [ __ ] eardrum and
then when you land it's the exact
opposite so when you're going up your
eardrum is getting
pushed out because the pressure is
higher there and then when you land it
becomes the opposite I believe that's
correct right yeah that's right because
as as you go back down again the
pressure becomes higher outside you hear
that's all that's going on and you can't
explain that to a baby I was barely able
to explain it to you so anyway she did
great on the plane she slept a lot and
then when she wasn't you know I just got
up and I was walking around with her and
you know flight attendants loved em I
heard of a lot of babies right and
fortunately my daughter's like really
cool it's got this thing when she just
kind of like she's met so many people
already that she's not freaked out by
people so when she meets someone new she
just like you know borderline in a rude
way just stares at them it takes her
like a good like three minutes and then
eventually she's like I I get who this
person is and then she smiles and then
turns away into your chest she gets a
little shy Oh would you look who's here
would you look who's here and she gives
me a wave and there she goes you're
going to come back out alright yes are
we able to do that it wasn't that bad
enough this is kind of cool like I'm uh
back in New York with the whole family
makes two in the road way better I can
tell you that now I just have to
convince my wife to come along with me
we got daughter when I go to like the
not fun places I've always given a [ __ ]
about that
you know she's always good to support me
you know when I go to a fun city you
know but when I go to like [ __ ]
Jacksonville Florida I'm on my own you
know which is really [ __ ] because I
have a lot of fun in that time you know
eat a little bit of alligator you go to
what gun range why not
anyways try to bring the energy up here
this [ __ ] hard one to do try to do
when I got to keep my voice down you
know
anyways so I'm totally back into my New
York vibe you know I really missed what
I lived in the simple living on the west
coast is I really missed the YES Network
when I lived here ten years ago
can't [ __ ] believe that I've been on
LA for ten [ __ ] years I used to
always you know I would watch the YES
Network and root against the Yankees
that was like my [ __ ] I never watched
the Mets I could never get into the
[ __ ] Mets but that's what I would do
I would watch almost every single Yankee
game as many of them as I could or watch
the replays when I got home and I would
just sit there and I would just root
against them but I mean you had to watch
him they were like this 200 million
dollar juggernaut and I used to always
go to Yankee Stadium I'd go by myself I
because I lived on the east side he'd
just jump on the [ __ ] what is that
the four five six take it right up to
the Bronx old Yankee Stadium
which was actually renovated old Yankee
Stadium and I would sit in like the
[ __ ] upper deck for like 12 bucks and
a keep score like an old man and I used
to watch Clemens and was it Mike Mussina
that whole era but I remember like in
1998 in the 1998 Yankees I got to go to
a couple couple games that year knowing
full well that I was watching what
looked like was going to be one of the
great teams of all time and you know 20
years later I still believe that and I
used to [ __ ] root against them
especially Clemens he's the root against
that guy hard and but so if I lived here
once again I would be going to games
because now they got Aaron judge and I
Jesus nadie you're looking good here
anyways I used to always go up there and
I would just root against but now they
got errant judge and even a Red Sox fan
you got to give it up to the [ __ ]
Yankees they're the greatest franchise
of all time as far as spotting Talent
do you realize for basically the last 80
out of 100 years that be a century man
hundred years is a century
you understand that huh okay why are you
climbing up where you going right now
okay for the last 80 out of the last 100
years they have scouted and picked the
guy there's no other [ __ ] franchise
out there they could say it they thought
okay
they'd bought Babe Ruth alright the Red
Sox [ __ ] owner was so goddamn
pussy-whipped he had to keep his [ __ ]
wife quiet and she wanted to [ __ ] I
don't know what the play was you know
but he needed to finance her [ __ ]
Broadway play - just shut the [ __ ] up
and he sells Babe Ruth no excuse for
that it's not like we didn't know who
the [ __ ] he was the guy was one inside
Young Awards I hid in the [ __ ]
zillion homeruns and we still get rid of
him because this [ __ ] lady had to get
a little tap dance [ __ ] Fauci [ __ ]
going right so they don't get credit for
that one I was a dumb move by the
[ __ ] Red Sox and everybody knew the
big was this [ __ ] however this is what
they've done for less 80 [ __ ] years
all right
from their farm system they went Lou
Gehrig to Joe DiMaggio to Mickey Mantle
right then June and they had a blue dip
George Steinbrenner comes in you know
the Oakland A's don't want to pay
anybody he buys the [ __ ] Oakland A's
they went to Championships [ __ ] all of
that then he buys Dave Winfield [ __ ] all
of that so bad 20 25 years in there okay
then [ __ ] Derek Jeter
I forgot home wait I forgot
what's-his-face Don Mattingly the only
reason why people don't look at him like
he's one of the greats because they
never won a [ __ ] World Series but Don
Mattingly - Derek Jeter
- Aaron judge you can argue with me on
Don Mattingly he wasn't quite one of the
greats of the greats but like this
[ __ ] Aaron judges it's like Paul
Bunyan's coming up to the plate six foot
seven just did you see that homeowner
yet against Seattle the other night he
almost [ __ ]
it out of his stadium you're not
supposed to be able to do that he hit it
so hard so [ __ ] far they maybe they
couldn't measure it I think they said
like 440 feet when she and I've heard of
[ __ ] going farther but it's like that's
just because this stop top of the
stadium stopped it
Jesus those seattle pitchers get lit up
don't they ever see that one McGwire hit
off of Randy Johnson he almost put a
hole in the roof of the [ __ ] King
dome
yeah that was a brutal combination of
like a like a hundred mile an hour pitch
meeting [ __ ] Andros team I thought
whatever the [ __ ] he was thought if
you're old enough to remember what it
was like to watch a Roy get up
professional athlete hitting baseballs
and watching that [ __ ] laser show
that those guys put on I don't think you
can argue that that steroids definitely
should be in the game they're gonna be
like the all they gotta do is just work
on the side effects and just get it down
just like we you know we got the at the
the vaporizer just if they do like
vaporize like steroids can you imagine
that you pull a muscle or whatever the
[ __ ] you feeling like an old man is just
breathe in that mist you [ __ ] muscles
repair like a goddamn x-men and every
day feels like the first day of spring
oh my god am i spinning Tony Bennett
every if I ruled the world every day
would be like the first day of spring so
they've done it like at what Erin judge
I just have that's the greatest [ __ ]
franchise of all time as far as their
ability to see the guy no the guy is the
guy and somehow sign him before anybody
else I don't know how the [ __ ] they do
it like how does everybody else miss out
on Erin judge I could see missing out on
Derek Jeter you know I could definitely
see that he was a kid you know one
another 6-3 6-4 [ __ ] guy I mean
there's a zillion of those but a 6-foot
set
guy coming up there like the [ __ ]
Jolly Green Giant like how do you miss
that guy somehow everybody does I know
there's probably some people out there
argument for the Lakers and I got to
give respect to the Lakers as far as in
my lifetime from 1968 until now the Los
Angeles Lakers have won more
championships than anybody else in my
lifetime believe it or not it is the
Lakers they won
see they won like one in the 70s five in
the 80s that's that's six and then they
won they won five with Kobe and a
thousand [ __ ] free agents so that's
11 and the only person that comes close
to that in my lifetime PETA Canadians
where they want at 68 69 71 73 sending
six 77 78 79 80 693 they won 10 anyways
but I don't count like the Lakers like
the real story of the Los Angeles Lakers
it's [ __ ] free agents you know like
when they always they always try to get
some of the join and be become part of
the history of the great Lakers centers
and every one of them's a [ __ ] free
agent except for the first giant white
dude that George whatever the [ __ ] his
name was own said Muresan what the [ __ ]
was that guy's name I don't he look like
a giant science teacher he actually
played with Minneapolis Mike and the
[ __ ] was his name I can't remember
anyways then you got Kareem he was a
Milwaukee buck right Shaq like they're
all just [ __ ] you know wilt they're
all just from someplace else so I have a
bad feeling that [ __ ] LeBron James is
going to go out there and that the
Lakers are eventually you know despite
whatever Danny Ainge does I just think
it's inevitable that the Lakers it will
pass the Celtics as far as number of
championships because for the simple
fact we cannot offer what the Lakers can
offer
I've said this before like this is our
pitch eight you know do you want to come
to racist Boston with shitty [ __ ]
weather and bang sixes or do you want to
go to racist [ __ ] Los Angeles [ __ ]
movie stars and feel like you're in
Hawaii with the weather you know I mean
we can't [ __ ] compete with that we
can't compete with that so that that's
[ __ ] it now you know and then like
our colors you know our [ __ ] mascots
a goddamned leprechaun I mean we just
can't get any whiter the Lakers have
like you know you know the colors are
somebody that has no money but they want
they want to [ __ ] and look like they're
doing something that's what the Lakers
colors up with the gold and the purple
you know the Lakers just scream new
money like you everyone we used to watch
those MTV Cribs and you'd watch some
[ __ ] idiot you know with the giant
[ __ ] you'd have like a fish tank in
his fireplace you know yet the fire
still works son you know like those you
look at that [ __ ] you like this guy's
going to go [ __ ] broke in this guy's
going to go pro he's got like 20 people
hanging out in this [ __ ] house this
guy's going to go broke that's when I
look at the Lakers uniform that's what I
see especially those old road ones those
purple ones I don't know I always
thought their uniforms were a little
silly
I like the home ones but the road ones
always look really silly to me but
anyways we were just like you know green
and white we got a [ __ ] Oh a top of
demony until yes [ __ ] mascot I mean I
can't imagine what Danny Ainge has to
say to people to try to get him to come
to Boston no no no no the N word that
was shouted at a Red Sox game this year
not at a Celtics game it's [ __ ] brutal
haven't said that though I feel like the
cops in LA beat the [ __ ] out of black
people way more I don't know it's a push
as far as like the racism it's a real
it's a push you know people always sit
there they try to act like all the
racism is
in the south and in Boston but you go
out to LA it's [ __ ] ridiculous they
got a black people quarantined you know
in this little area that's
coincidentally enough final approach for
[ __ ] LAX they got goddamn jets flying
over their [ __ ] heads every day
[ __ ] 500 feet off the [ __ ] ground
four runways all day long people just
landed on final [ __ ] approach you
know that wouldn't make you [ __ ] be
in a certain mood I know would would
make anyways let me read a little bit of
advertising here I know my stomach is
grumbling here this always happens when
I have the [ __ ] the recorded is so
I'm on my [ __ ] I have acting work
diet so I don't I go 12 hours without
from the last time I ate made about 10
o'clock last night something you have to
deal with the rumbling and the grumbling
here all right oh Jesus look who's back
everybody oh my god it's our old friends
old zip sorry I can't yell is she still
sleeping in the limo
are you hiring well are you do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates how how zipa crew [ __ ]
let's talk about the challenge of
finding great talent and/or importance
of finding great talent to a successful
business well I think it's
self-explanatory and I'm a one-man show
here so I don't know what to tell you
with zip recruiter you can post your
jobs 100 percent 100 plus job sites with
just one click then they're powerful
technology efficiently matches the right
people to your job better than anyone
else that's why is it the group is
different unlike other job resides it
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them in fact over 80% of jobs
posted on zip recruiter get qualified
candidates in just 24 hours it's like a
dating app except you're not going to
[ __ ] them you're going to make them go
to work right no juggling emails or
calls in your office simply screen rate
and manage candidates all in one place
with SIP recruiters easy to use
dashboard find out today why is it
has been used by businesses of all sizes
to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
right now my listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiters simple group for free
that's right free just go to zip
recruiter comm / / that's it included
comp / / one more time and try it for
free go to zip recruiter dot-com / /
[Music]
alright ah look who's back Oh would you
look who's back buh doo doo doo minion
DS me on DS Los Angeles's races - doo
doo doo doo bee undies biondi's if you
don't believe me ask a Jew I don't know
why they would no they look white to me
but da ba da Bo I don't know I'm [ __ ]
white and I could do whatever I want
dumb sorry I just woke up I haven't had
my [ __ ] cereal yet the undies
everybody the undies are this office
most comfortable underwear you'll ever
wear period and summer is the perfect
time to upgrade your underwear drawer
because everyone is thinking about
looking good and feeling good and the
undies are the ultimate feel-good undies
hey man and just make my undercarriage
feel right you know it's like you know
you know you feel when you listen to
easy listening just imagine your balls
feeling like that that's what it's like
wearing this underwear every pair of me
undies is sustainably sourced and made
for micro mode al modal a fabric that's
three times softer than cotton if you're
used to buying bluring underwear the
undies will change everything
I think underwear is exciting it's like
buying new socks you know you feel a
little spring in your step
same thing except it's with you dick
because beyond these come in all kinds
of colors and patterns and they release
new limited-edition patterns each month
that always sell out this month's
patterns were designed by the legendary
80's clothing brand crossed
colors with names that live up to their
bold designs and bright colors increase
the peace you dig and vog what the [ __ ]
is this is that for like [ __ ] black
guys over in their 50s that all sounds
like late 80s
[ __ ] that was spray-painted onto
somebody's jeans you got to see them for
yourself and right now you'll save 20%
off your first pair and receive free
shipping only at me undies comm slash
birth there's a reason the undies have
sold over 5 million pairs to date you'll
feel it when you put a month Jesus
Christ what's going to give you a handy
div and if you don't love your first
pair of me undies they're free get 20%
off your first pair plus free shipping
at the undies dot-com slash birth that's
me Andy's calm slash / one month time
high me on news.com slash / I know what
the [ __ ] problem is I usually have my
headphones on that usually helps with
the comedy if you can hear yourself I
don't know what it is you kind of need
to hear yourself hang on a second I
getting it cause here alright there we
go now back now I can hear myself
okay now the comedies on [ __ ] now now
here comes the [ __ ] here comes the
comedy that I read everything yet of
dull Oh Dollar Shave Club Tom shaved
club dude Dollar Shave Club it's this
matter choice you'll get a great shave
at a great price conveniently delivered
right to you do you no longer have to
schlep to the store I'll go using the
additional buy a cheap disposable razor
they give you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on razors with gimmicky shaving
technologies that you don't [ __ ] need
when you use the dollar shave club
executive razor with directed cavities
easy shave but up the blade gently
glides over your ball bag giving you a
smooth shave dr. Carvey shave butter
you know most porn stars most male porn
stars use dr. Carver's shea butter on
the [ __ ] scrotum you know if you ever
wondered when you're watching it you
know to get distracted by this move
balls you go yeah you know what how did
he get that way well there you go now
you know if you want porn star balls get
dr. Carver shea butter it's transparent
for money more precise shape helps
prevent ingrown hairs and fight razor
bumps make this smart choice
by joining Dollar Shave Club for a
limited time new members can get their
first month of the executive razor with
a tube a bid doctor can have use easy
shave leather for only 5 dollars with
free shipping and after that razors are
just a few bucks a month that's $15 $15
value for only $5 look at that there's
no hidden fees and no commitments cancel
anytime you like you can only get this
offer exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's jolly shave club.com / / all
right let's get back to the podcast
let's get back to the podcast and what
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh tell said I want to
talk about I don't know if I have
anything else to talk about so busy
stressing out getting picked up by the
sad van the sad van that always takes
you to this set it's a bare-bones van
it's always white with either gray or
black vinyl interior and you just get in
there and use like an ax I find it very
stressful this acting [ __ ] you know I
mean because I I never could just focus
on the day I always look at it like I'm
always looking at the entire shoot like
I've already thought like you know you
know this time next week I'll be done
you know rather than trying to enjoy it
so I learned a long time ago
I can't say I learned because I'm still
stressing about it but I just kind of
learned to be like okay you know I am
just going to just [ __ ] deal with
today when it comes to these acting gigs
and just be like we're doing this scene
and I'm going to make these choices and
this is what I'm going to do and I'm
gonna listen to the [ __ ] director if
he wants it this way I'll do it that way
bucket dick a day and then that'll be it
and then I'll go home and then I'll
memorize the lines for the next day and
then I'll just [ __ ] do that and I
just rather than [ __ ] looking over
the horizon just dealing with that
[ __ ] day
you know I know that sounds [ __ ]
weird but that's how I have to do it
cause if I don't do it that way then I I
you know I mean it's the kind of thing
that stops you from [ __ ] looking at
your taxes you know what I mean
if you're incorporated and you play like
quarterly taxes and [ __ ] you know or if
you if you don't pay quarterly you gotta
take the end of the years I [ __ ] end
of every month I get my receipts
together I get everything it [ __ ]
sucks
but only sucks for like an hour you
don't I mean as opposed to waiting the
entire [ __ ] year and it takes like
three days to get through the [ __ ]
it also lets me know what the [ __ ] I'm
spending and and all of that type of
ship so did that make any sense because
it didn't even make sense to me all
right why don't I just get out of this
[ __ ] and I'm just going to read a few of
these questions a couple these questions
all right on the alright for those who
listen to the podcast religiously or
maybe cut the last one I was asking like
how that expression came about because I
brought it up in the writers room I used
for efforts of family I was talking
about a cell on the arm and it was a
number of people that had never heard
that expression I said well it means
yeah it means it's free you know what to
pay for and then when I was looking it
up trying to figure out where it came
from it said it was a it came from like
law enforcement or whatever but
evidently I was wrong because someone
else went to another part of the
internet and they came up with this it
said bill here's what the Internet said
about on the arm or is what you found
that it said because what I found that
it said was above those from came from
the [ __ ] law enforcement this person
says to show their respects to the mafia
boss who protected their neighborhood or
fear of being extorted the store owners
would not allow them to pay for items
well if you're afraid that you're going
to be extorted I don't think that like
bowing down to somebody should make them
[ __ ] pay for it I would think but
anyways the store owners would take
their right hand and brush it against
their left arm as of way
saying forget about it no charge free
all right well where I looked at it that
it came came from law enforcement the
cops wouldn't pay for stuff I don't you
move [ __ ] knows it's the Internet
you don't know what's true you don't
know what isn't right
how far did you look how far onto the
internet did you go let me see how far
it took me to get okay on the arm here
we go on the arm origin come on man come
on internet work for me on the arm any
idea to his origin is it that the police
might have threatened with his gun I
doubt it but I'm just trying to figure
out this is what I get that's the first
one
the first one it's just one of these
what are these [ __ ] chat rooms by the
way and who and who are these people
into where are these things how do you
chime into these things you got to sign
in I'm on like word reference calm this
guy just writes this woman writes hi
there
I heard the phrase on the arm in the
movie Donnie Brasco about a mafia guy Al
Pacino as an undercover policeman
parenthesis Johnny Depp is their movie
that old he could have just said [ __ ] it
Donnie Brasco people know who's in it I
learned that it's police lingo for free
of charge any idea as to its origin is
it that the policeman might have
threatened with his gun I doubt it but
I'm just trying to figure the arm in
there like why would you present a
theory and then doubt your own [ __ ]
theory it was what the people's response
was okay dictionaries reference somebody
has this you click on this arm the upper
limb of the human body especially part
extending from the shoulder
with this series the upper limb to show
the form liver base something any arm
like attachment an administrative or
operational branch of an organization an
armored leg is a great deal of money arm
and arm arms linked together arm's
length on the arm
slang free of charge an investigation of
policemen who ate lunch on the arm put
the arm on to solicit or borrow money
from she put the arm on me for a
generous contribution to force or use
violence on you strung up you know what
I don't even give a [ __ ] this is what
happened by the time I get to this part
of the internet it's like I don't
[ __ ] care and there's usually
something I can click on on the side
like oh look at Tyson keep it real keep
it Tyson
check them out I guess it's some sort of
[ __ ] lunch me luck sure now what
about me [ __ ] I guess because it's on
the arm like they think somebody wants a
free sandwich catch it at a store near
you some giant fish a word of the day
highfalutin that's a word I thought that
was just something you sent of me Sam
would say dag burn highfalutin varmint
Dominic was at the back at a back table
talking to a suited man in the Somme
Bray in the sombre highfalutin English
he put on for four people of stature oh
it's like Madonna in this case probably
the noodle salesman I have no idea what
that sentence meant and I probably
mispronounced most of it but Donna puts
on the fake accident you know why does
she not act like she's just some
white-trash chick from Detroit she's got
that stupid English accent now
borderland
still love its own alright solution two
dudes girlfriend with the gross teeth oh
my god will this [ __ ] story ever end
hey Billy ginger Vitus yeah that's a
clever one I found a real
see solution for the dude said that's
dating the girl with gross teeth yes so
tonight per all you got to do is when
you're sitting down to watch a movie
just happen to put on Austin Powers
there's a couple of different scenes
where the woman Austin is trying to bang
and hints that Austin needs to brush his
gross [ __ ] teeth this would be a good
subtle way a girl to realize that maybe
she should take care of her own teeth
because believe me she knows they are
disgusting well who who walks around
knowing that they stink when she'd do
something about that and plus I don't
think that you know if you're with
somebody who's overweight if you put on
the Klumps you know
the Nutty Professor I mean I think I'll
just make them feel self-conscious and
bad about themselves and make the
overweight person want to go [ __ ]
binge eat more I don't know what the
gross person does they go eat some
[ __ ] [ __ ] head cheese with some
onions I don't know anyways he said you
could maybe even say something during
the scene like yeah why do British
people have gross teeth he goes I don't
know probably won't work but it's worth
a try it's just everybody just shits on
their own theories yeah dude this won't
work you know it won't work but it was
worth it for your Billy gingivitis it
also built have you been doing any
grilling or smoking this summer I
recently did some smoked chicken wings
and they were the best wings I've ever
ate hands down thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself no my my my grill my big green
egg and my flat top grill has been like
you know if they were a car and have
them up on blocks right now I just been
so swamped with the work you know and I
got the kid and it's just like I don't
know occasionally I will crank the thing
up and I get into it but I've been super
super [ __ ] busy writing writing and
running but I got to tell you something
man I actually really enjoy writing like
I hate the notes part and having to pull
it apart I get frustrated with that but
that really is part of it people always
goes well you know what they say writing
is rewriting I always want to be like
yeah is that what they say yeah like
whatever the [ __ ] you do for a living
can you imagine if you just [ __ ] if
you if you put in floors and you put in
all the floors and and then somebody
comes in and tells you to rip up most of
it you know and you're like really and
hey you know what flooring is flooring
is reflooring once you want to just take
the board and just [ __ ] smash your
own head in with it you just weren't
conscious so you wouldn't have to live
that life anymore well that's the life
of a writer but I actually I really find
that I like doing it and I think just by
hanging out with all of these writers
that have been doing it for so long
obviously they're way better than I am
but you just kind of start to absorb how
to write stories and [ __ ] like that
which was always my problem I could
always write dialogue but I just
couldn't get the story from the
beginning to the end like my brain just
didn't work that way I could write
scenes I think that's why I became a
comedian because I it's like oh look at
that that's a funny joke that's a funny
little scenario and done I don't have to
[ __ ] take the ball from the one-yard
line all the way to the end zone like
like writers have to you know I was on
special teams
I was a wedge breaker was it that was
the [ __ ] level of artistry that I was
doing there what am i up to there 41
minutes out Jesus Christ bail 41 minutes
of [ __ ] mediocrity all right
microchipping oh god don't even get me
started on this
I just cannot [ __ ] but like I just
can't [ __ ] believe this [ __ ] do you
know Delta Airlines wants to start using
people's fingerprints as a way for you
to get on the [ __ ] plane and do you
know that most people won't have a
problem with it they're so [ __ ]
stupid
it's like there's so many people out in
the world it's almost like you know what
- why don't you just become a [ __ ]
slave
like how much you going to give to these
people how underpaid uh politicians that
they will not stand up to these people
these corporations I swear to god the
sitting there wasting all this [ __ ]
time with Isis and all this other
[ __ ] these [ __ ] corporations the
mothership that they're doing to their
own goddamn countrymen which they really
don't have because they're [ __ ]
global they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything about just trying to make more
[ __ ] money and they want they're
going to start microchipping people this
was complex constant company to implant
mic implant microchips in employees and
like like five people already agreed to
it they're going to take something
foreign that's not natural to your body
and they're going to stick it underneath
your [ __ ] skin they're going to know
where you are at all [ __ ] times and
all these [ __ ] Dhokla hair you know
if you're not doing anything wrong with
your [ __ ] problem
here's the [ __ ] problem okay just
because you're a [ __ ] dope doesn't
mean the rest of the world is okay I
think it's safe to say that me and
everybody else listening to this thing
for the most part was not as smart it's
[ __ ] George Washington right fair
enough okay well here's the deal if
George Washington was microchipped and
all his [ __ ] buddies from microchip
this [ __ ] country wouldn't exist
because they would have known where he
was they would have gone over there and
they would have [ __ ] killed him and
that would have been the end of the
[ __ ] rebellion so what you're doing
is you're having faith that these
[ __ ] people at the top who have not
even remotely demonstrated on any
[ __ ] level at any point in history
that they give a flying [ __ ] about
anybody other than themselves are going
to you're going to turn over that level
of power you're going to get
fingerprinted by Delta [ __ ] Airlines
like you've committed some sort of a
[ __ ] crime if [ __ ] airline is
going to have your [ __ ] fingerprints
who in the [ __ ] do they think they are
do you don't I went to buy my car they
asked for my thumbprint I was like I'm
not getting my [ __ ] fingerprints -
you're a car dealership the goal is just
to protect you now it isn't yet douche
you're going to sell this to somebody
it's part of my profile I think that
just they're collecting they're all
sharing information about you what you
buy where you live what your social
security
you [ __ ] fingerprints they're going
to get it all the way down to your
[ __ ] DNA it's under and these
politicians will not push back on any
level because the president makes five
hundred grand a year
that's the highest-paid political office
is five hundred [ __ ] grand a year and
they need a hundred million dollars to
get the job I don't have a hundred
million you don't have a hundred million
corporations do and that's what they owe
it to so they just look the other
[ __ ] way
and what do they do they sit there and
they [ __ ] on [ __ ] comedians
constantly going after do you hear what
he said about Caitlyn Jenner and they
look the other way with pharmaceutical
companies handing out [ __ ] opiates
like they've given up flyers to some
sort of jam band and now we got this
heroin [ __ ] problem they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't say anything about it
sorry I know I'm [ __ ] losing my [ __ ]
here but like what they've done to the
food supply what the [ __ ] they do what
the bankers have done left all these
people upside down in their own [ __ ]
houses what they've done to the water
supply fracking causing earthquakes in
parts of the world that never had
[ __ ] earthquakes [ __ ] up the
drinking water you know they got to send
a [ __ ] pipeline of the [ __ ] Native
Americans land I mean like like we
haven't done enough to those [ __ ]
people
you know deer any politicians talking
about that now nobody talks about that
[ __ ] but God so [ __ ] bid you do a
[ __ ] joke in a strip mall and they're
[ __ ] all over it then that becomes
like some big goddamn story
this is [ __ ] horrific and it makes me
happy then 49 years of age the fact that
I think I'm going to maybe get to live
half a [ __ ] century without a [ __ ]
airline having my fingerprints and be
walking around with the goddamn
microchip you know I love that I lived
50 years before the [ __ ] oh Jesus
she's up huh
I love that got to live 50 years before
robots showed up it's just
it's just greed and power completely
100% out of control and I hate like this
is I'm reading this is iWitness ABC News
so these guys are all bought and paid
for CNN's bought and paid for Fox News
is bought people they're all [ __ ]
bought and paid for because the same
people I just brought brought up they
advertise on their [ __ ] networks so
they have to watch what they say because
they don't want to lose the ad money
because that's how they get paid right
so they always have like dental gee this
is a little unsettling you know they
always come back from it
when they show some [ __ ] robot you've
ever seen egg watch at the local news or
they show somebody getting microchip and
they always come back to the anchors and
kind of do that whoo it's kind of good
and then they just move on to the next
thing but some [ __ ] old lady who
makes her own jam like that's supposed
to make you feel better at the end of
the [ __ ] newscast there's some puppy
that they thought was lost and [ __ ]
snipped its way back to the station
wagon three towns away right whenever
the [ __ ] they leave you on now
corporations are completely out of
control they've been out of control my
entire life and now it's reaching a
level that it's like you're watching a
bad sci-fi movie I think it's [ __ ]
insane what why the [ __ ] do you need my
fingerprints as a [ __ ] airline wheel
[ __ ] you you're not the FBI
you're not the government you're a
[ __ ] airline yourfinger prison this
is the thing people will do people will
[ __ ] do all of this so they don't
have to stand in a line
don't let them scan their [ __ ] retina
they'll give them a [ __ ] baby just so
they can be pre checked that's all you
got to do you just hold a little cookie
out and the average [ __ ] mouth breathe
and [ __ ] [ __ ] but you know something
I don't
I swear to god I mean this is really
cynical but I you walk around and I find
that half the [ __ ] people should be
microchipped you should know what he's
[ __ ] idiots are
[Laughter]
I'll never forget that guy galloping
sideways on that Trump rally screaming
at all these stupid liberals going [ __ ]
political correctness build the wall
build the wall if he's [ __ ] galloping
like like that was going to make his
life better like that was what was
holding him back I swear to God like I I
don't give a [ __ ] how dumb you are you
have to know as a white dude if you were
born in the United States of America
okay you're not going to get a better
starting block than that all right and
if you can't figure out some sort of
game I mean if you're going to [ __ ]
blame anybody why are you going to look
down you got to go up that's what's
[ __ ] you over Democrats and
Republicans [ __ ] you over I just
don't get how people don't see that but
I'm like most people I feel like my
ideas are right and no one else has a
good point unreal this [ __ ] car
dealership can we get you a thumbprint
it's like ya know you guys sell cars you
understand that you guys lie for a
living
other salesmen who live for a living
turn the other way you let you turn the
other way when they see a car sailing
you like that you like the bottom of the
barrel [ __ ] salesmen yeah I'm gonna
give you my fingerprint you know why
they said they wanted my figure to go
just in case somebody comes in and tries
to is an impostor and pretends that
they're you and tries to buy a car and I
just looked at the guy and I was like
you know what I'm going to take my
chances on that the guy literally goes
in this one killed me he goes you're the
first person we've ever had say no to
that now I hope he's just being a car
salesman and he was lying to me and that
was his last-ditch effort to try to
convince me but the other part is he's
actually telling the truth
like then what happens is what this is
how they do it is most people adults so
they don't think and then what happens
is becomes a herd mentality and all they
got to do is get most of the her to
start running over the [ __ ] cliff and
you you have to do it too because if you
don't then you're just going to be
[ __ ] sitting there all by yourself
like hey I'm not going to have a cell
phone hey I'm not going to have this I'm
not going to have that and then your
life the way you're going to lead it
becomes extremely limited the next thing
you know you're [ __ ] half naked
walking around your backyard trying to
like trap squirrels so you can eat that
day because you're not doing what
everybody else is doing and it's just
you know it's going to be the worst is
when they try to convince when they try
to convince people to do it right
there's going to be some politician
getting it lift that [ __ ] smile on
his face where he's like I don't want to
do this but I have to do this I have to
do this so I can go on the post
president [ __ ] you know $70,000,000
speaking tour where I go out and I give
speeches to the same [ __ ] people that
put me into office like the hero of all
heroes presidents Obama is about to do
he just he has that [ __ ] has 69
million dollars with the gigs on the
books coming up you know I will never
for the life of me understand why that
guy people look like liberals look at
that guy like he [ __ ] did something
for him I will never get that it's like
that guy had his face in the pig trough
just like everybody else I mean I don't
know I don't know what it is I think
it's because he's sandwiched between two
of the worst public speakers of all time
Bush and [ __ ] Trump you know what I
mean I think if he came after Clinton
where Clinton wasn't the gray as a whole
although but he got enough the women
[ __ ] loved him I will never get that
either how much women love that [ __ ]
big [ __ ] baby he we look at goofball
Jesus doll there any presidents that you
like yeah I lighted mine the first
George Bush the [ __ ] war hero and I
liked
I like Jimmy Carter anyways all right B
of a outage hey banker bill I work for B
of a and from the customer service side
that outrage was very stressful if you
haven't already mentioned it slash found
out the outrage was a result of Jesus
Christ this guy works for the [ __ ]
Bank he's going to he's going to tell me
what happened he can't even spell the
words were I don't I don't you wrote
half a word here buddy
se ve are a sever reboot is that
supposed to be a severe reboot is sever
a word I don't maybe I'm wrong I was
told for my boss my boss's boss in
passing when he was leaving work one of
the tech guides managing the server ran
a program to check for viruses and [ __ ]
okay this guy manages your money check
for viruses and [ __ ]
thank God he talks like me and the
program made Jesus Christ the program
made that one particular server to shut
down causing the rest of our online
products to not work that's a sentence
by a guy works at a bank the program
made that one particular server to shut
down to shut down the program made that
one particular server shutdown is that
we mean causing the rest of our online
products to not work the bank had to
restart all the servers to sync that
tech crap up resulting in the six-hour
delay from the call center side we could
still see all the balances and account
information clients themselves just
couldn't process any maintenance nothing
made my day more enjoyable than
apologizing to client after client for
our system error had a few people in the
situation you mentioned on Thursday what
where they stuck outside the country
with no money
Oh had a few people in this situation
you mentioned on
stay where they are stuck outside the
contest guy is a [ __ ] this guy we
should have been in summer school next
to me totally agree you need to have
backup plans when it comes to accessing
your money whether it be multiple bank
accounts or stuffing some cash
underneath the pillow where you rest
your bulb freckle dome at night keep
doing what you're doing and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah I've never met a banker
that believes in the banking system if
you really talk to them about it they're
nervous too I don't know anyways was
that supposed to make me feel better I
mean I guess it's good that no one
hacked into your system you guys just
kind of were running something something
dead [ __ ] up but he agreed with me you
have a little money here a little money
there a little money there don't have it
all your eggs in one basket we all know
that right
because then everything's going to be on
the arm with the [ __ ] one full of the
Cuckoo's Nest all right much older man
okay here we go well I'm at some point
I'll 56 okay I mean that I'm in all
right much older man bill burr how hi
yeah I've been listening to your
policies from a lady I love it I love
when the ladies write in you guys don't
do it enough I've been listening to your
podcast for a little over a year
basically since the day I discovered
them and I've seen all your specials
hope to catch you live on his page well
thank you so here goes
I've been living for eight years and
married for four of those years to a man
who was 21 years older than me yeah we
met when he was 45 and I was 23 and we
have been together since Mia can you do
this one enough you can okay we have a
two-year-old son and I am now 31 and he
is 52 okay I know many think that when
they first heard my husband that my
husband is well old enough is well old
enough to be my father that it's some
sort of sugar daddy situation which
honestly is not the case at all our
lives are quite simple
we live in a four-bedroom house I own
two soccer we own two soccer mom type
vehicles the only expensive piece of
Julie to my name is my wedding ring and
one would not find a pair of bud bottom
shoes in my closet but I digress
only so folks don't get the wrong
picture for the past year or so it seems
like he is aged mentally in a drastic
way our age difference was never an
issue until the last year or so oh look
who's here hey buddy hey buddy are you
doing are you doing you're making a lot
of racket out there aren't you it is
called a podcast anyways so anyways me
here's the deal this this lady is
married to this guy he's 21 years older
ah
what's going on yeah these are
headphones she's looking at me like what
is this what is this so if you're gonna
keep looking at me was that cute little
smile how do I do this alright so uh
yeah she was 23 he was 45 so I guess
he's 22 years older when they met 23 and
45 yeah and now she's 31 and he's 52 I
don't know somehow he was 22 years older
now he's only 21 must be when their
birthdays are but anyways she said it
wasn't a sugar daddy thing they don't
really have a lot of money they're just
living a basic lifestyle oh you got
stuff smiling kid I'm totally losing my
train of thought here he's just too
adorable too adorable for me to do this
yeah I know that's what that's my
listeners who don't can you get through
this please so basically she said the
only expensive piece of jewelry she has
is her wedding ring she doesn't every
red-bottom shoes she just basically
really loves the guy okay so but for the
past year or so it seems like he is aged
mental
in a drastic way our age difference was
never an issue until the last year or so
he seems to be almost bitter than I am
in my 30s and he's beginning to become
Beyond insecure that I will decide I
want a younger man out of nowhere one
day I'm all over the place with this she
says seems like you're pretty focused
sorry anyway his constant insecurity and
vastly changing behavior is really
causing issues in our marriage that I
believe may never go away being that our
age difference is not going away
anywhere obviously was hoping for some
of your wife input on my current
situation or tell me I'm a dumbass for
marrying an older man older man than my
father like my mother does have a good
one and of course go [ __ ] yourself so
what do you think Mia yeah he was
probably too old for you because now
that's just too much of an age if he's
older than your dad do you have daddy
issues maybe well regardless it seems
like the power dynamics have shifted so
before you were a young you know
impressionable thing and he was the
older wiser more in control now he's
getting older he's becoming aware of his
mortality and you're in your 30 is what
you're like you're towards your peak now
as a woman like that's when you really
peak and you're actually in your 40s but
you're getting there you're probably
still hot you're smarter than you were
before you're on top of your game worse
again he's feeling some type of way so I
don't know if he's having a midlife
crisis yeah I don't know if he's having
a midlife crisis and you're going to end
up being collateral damage or or what's
going on but I should probably have like
a frank discussion about it but yeah if
he's afraid of you leaving him he might
be having some kind of a midlife crisis
all right let's have the frank
discussion for her I'll be the guy all
right well you want to be the guy no you
be the guy because you're the or an
actual older guy in our relationship so
I don't figure that's just like two one
the nose casting no it's
we can we can we can do it that way so
you're the older guy and I'm the hot
young nubile wife okay well you're gonna
go out where you gone you're going out
will I get me older I got some [ __ ] done
know where that where you know I'm going
on with my girlfriend I told you that
did you not do not remember yeah okay
well I'll be back soon why are you
telling I told you last night that I was
going out my girlfriend's tonight where
are you going out wearing that I'm going
up I'll bring you back something fine
goes to have an affair with my young
lover what do you think you should do
just have a talk with him and if he is
like what is that noise let's just sound
a dump truck makes when it backs up
before it dumps the load of attack Mary
the guy she shouldn't just like
completely jump ship but if it's like if
he's becoming unbearable and you know
difficult to live with and he won't make
any strides to work it out then why
doesn't he take like those legal roads
that those old guys that are all
shredded you know they jump in the pool
and they come out and all those those
women would sit in the pool like look at
that old guy then he comes out of the
pool and they're like oh wait a minute
right
I think I'll bang that grandpa well
maybe two because their lives like just
a very less modest lifestyle he's
feeling even more insecure that he
doesn't have anything to like offer so
even if you wanted to get out of it to
like go back to a younger girl or
something like younger than her he
wouldn't have anything necessarily its
offer so yeah this guy's an idiot oh
yeah I want to married a girl a younger
I'm a time before I met you Nene yeah I
was like Oh was I 35 or something one of
those what I mean I was 25 year or 35
all right so I was like whatever 34 35
and I met this woman right she was like
22 21 22 and she said the first night we
hung out she goes where is this going
I remember she told me this story yeah
and I said where's it going I go nowhere
I go Bonilla 30 maybe like 106
yeah
so this isn't going anywhere so I won't
say what I said next but it worked out
well
all right that's the that's the pocket
you this is their new thing she just
grabs you got such a grip that's my
forearm here you just grabbed a whole
handful of all right I want to hang out
what their before he has to go to work
so I got to get off the thing here yeah
you're just fascinated with anything
that's technology there's no screen on
it so that's boring right got a light on
it it's got a light on it oh it's got a
light on it doesn't it hmm I always
think you can't get any cuter than you
get through them huh all right okay cool
hang on a second I'll hang out with you
in a minute all right that's the podcast
my daughter's here go F yourselves and
I'll check in on you on Thursday there